わかるもう治りかけなんですけどここ二つまめができてます。
これなんでできたかというと釣りのゲームあるじゃないですかあのゲーセンであのメダル入れてヒュウってやったらこう
15枚つかったらいいロットが使えるみたいな、その、なんか釣りのゲームでボスのめちゃくちゃでかい黄色の魚がいたんですよ。
そいつめちゃくちゃ釣りにくいらしいんですけど、僕一発で釣れて、もうね、ぶいやぁぁぁぁぁってもうめっちゃ回して釣れてめっちゃメダル１００枚ぐらいきたんですけども
これがもう異常な力すぎて指のまめが二つ潰れて血が止まりませんでした。
ふん、ぴゅぴゅぴゅん
コンビニってすごい量のグミありませんか。
まずまさにいまここにあるのがそれですわ。
僕がまだ赤子だったときは、３つか４つぐらいだったような気がする。
やっぱグミって売れるのかな。売れてるか知んないんですけどきずいたらものすごい量のグミが販売されててやばいでしょ種類が
グミっグミの種類が多すぎる。きずいたらこんだけの種類のグミがコンビニに売ってました。
これちょコンビニに売ってたグミ全種類です。
今回は素朴な疑問。味多すぎないっすか。うん
コンビニのグミの種類が多すぎて、どれを食べていいかわからない
そんなときが僕たまにあるんですけども
これだけいろんなグミの味を出すってゆうことは
皆さんおいしいグミを作ろうと
努力している訳でございます
このすごい
もうすごい競争社会よ!グミ!
もうアイドルの戦国時代並に
今グミの戦国時代が来ている訳ですよ
グミ美味しくて売れるから
美味しいグミを出せば売れるんじゃないかと思って
いろんな会社がたくさんのグミを作っているわけですよ今！
そうして気づいたらコンビニでこんなたくさんの種類のグミが販売されていた現状でございますなう！
でやっぱりみなさん目指すところは一つなんですよ
美味しいグミを作ること
ただ一つ（確信）
ということはこいつらを全員ひとまとまりにして
一粒のグミにしたら
それは一番美味しいんじゃないか
要するにみんなあれでしょ
ね、みなさん
目指しているところは一緒でしょ？
一緒なんですよ、みなさん
美味しいグミを作りたい、その一心で
いろんな会社の方は頑張っているんで
これ全部まとめて一つのグミにしたら
それが多分、、至極
もう史上最高に美味しいグミなんじゃないかという結論に至ったので
今回これを全部混ぜて
一つのグミを作っていこうと思います
では
いこっ
よし、やっていくぞよ
ピュレグミ
ピュレグミ　紫
マスカット
サワーズグミのラムネ
噛み応えが強すぎて
グレープ
基本的に全部食べたことあるな俺
ポイフル
4種類あるから4種類入れるよ
やああああ
フェットチーネグミのレモン
ピーチ
ぎゃあああ
ソーダ
ぎゃああ
コーラ
ハリボーグミのゴールデン
終わりっ
ハリボーグミのグレープフルーツ
ふああああ
果汁グミ　みかん
えへ
果汁グミ　いちご
うぇぃ
ぶどう
うぇぃ↑
ハリボーグミ　コーラ
いえええぇぇぇ
あああああああ
弾力が桁違いだったな
フェットチーネグミ　グレープ
ぴええええええええ
果汁グミ
スゲェな、ちょっと健康志向か？w
果汁グミ　美味しくコラーゲン
肌にいいのか？
ひょっとしてスゲェなんか体にいいグミができる気がしてきたゾ
さけるグミ
うわ、スッゴ、なんか
これはすごいな
べええああ
GOCHI
ジュレピュレ
ぽおお
ピュアラルグミ　ピーチ
これスゲェ柔らかいな
ぺええええええええ
ピュアラルグミ　りんご
ぺえええええ
ヘルシースナッキング
もうわかんn
ぺえええ
コーラアップ
わああ
ハートボイルドw
ぺえええ
コロロ2種類
ポォイ
カルピスグミ２種類
こいつは全く読めねぇな
果たしてどんな味になるのでしょうか
はい、ということでグミが全種類出揃いました！
もうバラバラよぉ↓、まったくまとまりのないグミたち
みんなバラバラってことはやっぱいろんな楽しみ方があるわけじゃないですかグミを
やわらかくてこの果汁があふれるグミもあれば
かみごたえが固いハードなグミ
健康志向のグミもあれば鉄分のとれるグミもある
本当にグミってだけでいろんな種類の味わい方があるやつを
俺が今から一つにまとめてやるお
Haaaaa!!!
いやぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
うわぁぁぁぁぁ
ﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝﾄﾞﾝ
ｽﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃﾃ
ﾊｧ　ﾊｧ　ﾊｧ　ﾊｧ
きもぉ!!
ハード((ぶわぁ!!キモイ!!
ひとまずハードグミ系がかなりキツいっすね
うわぁもう・・・
うぇぇぇぇぇ!!
これを今からひとかたまりにするんですけども熱を使います
え、ちょっと溶けてる間に頑張って
そうそそそそうそう
そそそういうそのそういうの
そういうのよぉ!!
こういう感じでちょっとずつ溶かしていきましょう
オッケーいいのではないでしょうかぁ？
適量の大きさにして
冷蔵庫で冷やして
ちゃんとグミになるのを待ちます
では
はいんないんだけど
ぐぬぬ
ぐぬぬぅ
くそぉ
そのまま落ちてほしいのぉ
ﾊｧｯﾊｧｧｧｧｧｧ!!!!
どうすんだよこれ
やばいじゃんもうエイリアンVSプレデター
うわもぅna、ちょ、なに
あなたたち本当にグミなの?
のびるのが得意なfriendsなんだねぇすご
ｼｭｼｭｼｭｼｭｼｭ
ちょ、ちょ、あんたじゃないよ
じゃ早速、冷やしてきます
(意味深)
何があった
はい、というわけでひとます固まったんですけども
意味がわからない
あなたに関しては何がどうなっているんだ
ただこれでひとまず全部のグミが合体してる味になるので
おいしいのは間違いないと思いま
Suaaaaaaaaaa
では早速食べてみたいと思います
いただきます!!
んん??
うわぁ歯ごたえがすごいよ
ﾋﾟｷｯ
うああ
うんうん
んん!!
あ!
ハイチュウだぁ!!
次回のはじめしゃちょーの歌
(♪)今日～、の動画～を～
(♪)見てくれて～、ありがと～う～
(♪)次回の～はじめんも、
(♪)お楽し~み~に